[Music]
a little Williams one of the best in the
league you do not call timeouts so that
the other team can game plant for you
guys like Lou Williams are so good they
can just figure it out on the flats
exactly what he did took the clock all
the way down and when you're a shot
maker like Lou William George here it's
just fine for you to take that shot
basically it's a buzzer to win the game
not many guys make that shot Lou
Williams is one of them play right there
Lou time to double foul he did we gets
the basket to go
o3o block you know what Ralph it is a
prayer but like lose those for Lou
always go in so it's like it's a prayer
for everybody except for him just knows
how to find the rim off-balance
defenders on them or to close the game
inside the two-minute mark any overtime
that's just an amazing job Eponine he is
unbelievable Ralph McKinney's
fallen-down he runs into him and flips
it in the crazy job
the hand-eye coordination on guys like
Lou Williams is never never a doubt
reset to 14 now eight millions defended
by Forbes
[Applause]
29 feet away and he gives his team
believe 40 seconds to go want to go to
his lab Yano ball fake back to Lube one
bond cook we got a lock on to 24 Lou
Williams oh no eyebrow the to what was
over Lynas right foot was on the line
[Music]
so a big finish to the period for the
Lakers two seconds to go Luke Williams
from midcourt momentum swings one way
and just that quickly it swings back the
other way white shirt we'll see here the
ball left boy is close
Wow closer than I thought Josh Hart just
took a little off of guarding Luke
Williams and he was able to tee it off
from half-court Wow didn't leave his
hand before the red lights around the
board come up one more time we watch oh
yes
that baskets good Wow
great five seconds summers bringing in
five seconds ago tie game seatbelts are
fastened Luke Williams for the win
goodness that just happened
move will become everybody in the gym
new blue whales was going to shoot this
shot easily got it off in time they got
nothing but nylon what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content